[Music]
software development is the lifeline of
every business today digitization is
pushing each to innovate create and
deliver applications faster than ever
traditional software development can't
keep up anymore so what can DevOps today
every organization that depends on
software in its products services and
operations is looking to adopt DevOps
methods and practices these
organizations need skilled DevOps
professionals who are ready from the day
they are hired to help them turn ideas
into market ready software applications
simply learn is proud to introduce the
postgraduate program in DevOps in
collaboration with the California
Institute of Technology Center for
technology and management education hi
i'm raquel nur program director at the
California Institute of Technology
welcome to the post graduate program in
DevOps
offered by Cal Tech Center for
technology and management education in
collaboration with simply Life Cal Tech
is a world-renowned science and
engineering Institute that marshals some
of the world's brightest minds and most
innovative tools to address fundamental
scientific questions and pressing
societal challenges the DevOps
postgraduate program includes master
classes led by Cal Tech instructors
their expertise in software engineering
will show you how to apply your new
skills in the broader context of
emerging technologies and business
applications software engineering
requires a balance of technical skills
operational management and team
engagement along with Cal Tech's
expertise simply learns blended learning
methodology is the best platform for
adult learning in DevOps we focus on
applied learning not passive learning
and make sure you have the most
in-demand DevOps skills our program
provides the best elements of
traditional classroom education to
online blended learning combines
self-paced elearning instructor-led live
virtual classrooms hands-on labs and
projects with 24/7 learning support
simply learns platform provides ample
peer-to-peer interaction with your
fellow learners Caltech has partnered
with simply learned to develop this
comprehensive program for you this
postgraduate program not only covers the
core concepts of DevOps
from code repositories and version
control to continuous integration
continuous delivery and from
configuration management to
containerization but it also provides
hands-on experience in continuous
deployment using configuration
management tools like puppet chef and
ansible you will build design and
maintain cloud-based containers and
applications on cloud and work with
tools such as git Jenkins docker
kubernetes and more in this high
engagement program you will immediately
apply what you learn through online labs
projects and interactions with
instructors and peers the program
culminates in a DevOps capstone project
that you can add to your portfolio to
showcase your new skills and expertise
to potential employers the Cal Tech's
simply learn postgraduate program fits
into your budget and your schedule you
access all aspects of the program from
your own home or office and the cost is
a fraction of the tuition and expenses
of an equivalent on-campus program
combining the best of industry expertise
and academic rigor this program will
unlock doors and get you noticed by top
employers such as Google Amazon and
Microsoft program graduates also earn
twenty five CEUs from Caltech to satisfy
employee development and professional
licensure requirements upon graduation
from the program you will receive your
certificate of completion at an
exclusive online convocation event
you'll also be awarded membership in the
prestigious Caltech circle where you can
access technology and career information
and events and expand your professional
network entering this program is a smart
decision you can expect to be challenged
and pushed but you'll emerge with one of
the most in-demand skill sets for
businesses in any industry anywhere in
the world now you have the opportunity
to transform your future by becoming a
DevOps professional to get started in
this unique program just complete our
brief program application and an
admissions counselor will walk you
through prerequisites and how this
program can best meet your specific
career objectives